Oscar-winning composer James Horner has died in a plane crash in southern California.
He was flying a single engine aircraft, one of several owned by the 61-year-old,...
...which crashed on Monday morning in the Los Padres National Park in Ventura County.
Nominated for ten Academy Awards, Horner won two for 1997's Best Picture Titanic,...
...one for the Film Score...
...and one for its enduring, arguably irritating, theme song My Heart Will Go On,...
...sung by Celine Dion.
He also regularly collaborated with James Cameron, not just on Titanic,...
...but also Aliens and Avatar.
Outstanding.
Horner will arguably be best remembered for his epic, emotive, soulful music scores.
One of the best examples is Braveheart, another Oscar-nominated soundtrack,...
...where one moment he uses music to heighten the atmosphere of a love scene,...
...to the spine-tingling contrast of rallying the troops to fight.
That they may take our lives, but they'll never take our freedom!